hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and
that guy was not ready for this not
ready at all i thought there was a lot
going on in the first half of this sake
i didn't finish the intro properly
deal with it there's no time for that
because i thought there was a lot going
on during shibuya but that was a whole
lot of nothing compared to part two and
in the interest of time please do feel
free to insert your own subscribe joke
as well as your own subscription to the
new world review for regular jiu jitsu
kaisen
stuff and things look i'm tired very
tired but in such a great way
the second half of shibuya was an
overload of just
everything action drama exposition lore
dumping revelations and tiny pieces of
comedy here and there
and really even a mere half of this arc
might have been a bit
too much to read all at once so all we
can do is see how we did
for reference we are picking up a
chapter 110 which is part
28 of the shibuya incident already
pretty wild
and let's conclude our thoughts on toji
i really don't think this character
could have been implemented any better
in this situation he provides a
convincing out for how our character is
going to defeat dagon
a great action spectacle and really cool
interactions with fushiguru i suppose i
should say megami because we are now
dealing with two fushiguros
but i love the anomaly that was toji's
existence explained by the idea that the
old lady's curse technique runs out and
reverts when her grandson's energy hits
its limit and the fact that toji's body
consumes no cursed energy basically
makes him a permanently existing murder
puppet which i suppose was a really
really stupid thing to do in retrospect
because with those conditions in mind or
maybe it wasn't actually maybe the idea
was that the grandson would just inherit
toji's raw strength and not have the
body take command because
who could have predicted that certainly
nobody who takes a typical view of what
the soul is
doesn't matter though because what we
have here is a sort of toji redemption
because there is a short flashback that
actually makes him out to be
something of a considerate father the
whole selling mega me off because he
would be better placed in life elsewhere
and like i know it's
it's not much but it's more care than
i've been led to believe he had so far
and i do also really like the end of
this character
recognizing megami and then deciding to
kill himself after hearing that he took
the fush guru name instead of the zenin
name it was such a sudden
but quite beautiful end which is a
statement i could make about a fair few
characters in this half of the ark but
we'll get to that because first up we
have much more to discuss with fushiguro
jr for a long long time i've been
wondering why sukuna has such a keen
interest in him it's a plot point that's
been dropped what like at least three
four times now i'm not sure if i've ever
bothered to comment on it because these
are more review style videos rather than
speculation
but it's becoming pretty damn clear
there was a fun flashback where gojo
essentially implied that the user of the
10 shadows technique could theoretically
rival the user of limitless and sick
size so fushiguro 100 holds the
potential to become an absurd beast of
gojo quantities which we have slowly
been drip-fed throughout the series
honestly fushiguro not all that
impressive in the early arcs of jujutsu
kaisen so i do very much praise akutami
for the slow burn revelation of exactly
what sort of madness he's capable of
which may or may not have culminated
here the idea that he can summon a whole
series of shikigami at any time
including the um all right okay let's
let's try and say this
the eighth handled sword divergent silla
divine general maharaja
that thing such a mouthful but it's a
pretty scary last-ditch ever technique
coercing an opponent into a ritual with
you
and particularly the maharaja's ability
to adapt to any
and all phenomena oh and there was also
this beautiful panel where it
immediately becomes clear that yes
megami is toji's son because look at the
sheer pleasure at the idea of an
opponent being slaughtered alongside him
it's just
it's something both satisfying and
terrifying also fascinating to think
about because it's a trait that all
three of our first years have
in battle each of them are capable of
exuding what seems to be this like
chillingly creepy presence like kugisaki
fights with a permanent sense of crazed
focus
fush guru has this and his insane
laughter and yuji becomes
hyper hyper-focused on killing albeit
generally only to do with majito but all
of our protagonists have this immense
darkness with them which for want of a
better word is fun but i'm still
wondering if there's more to ten shadows
than this though particularly because
the maharaja has never been tamed either
way fushigo's potential is even more
insane than i thought and sukina going
to such extents to keep him alive makes
a lot more sense now
having brought up sukuna holy hell the
absolute battle of the ark has to go to
sukuna
versus the maharaja is it maharaja or is
it maharaga
it's probably maharagar and my brain
just like kicked into indian mode
but uh look i'm not re-recording it so
we're just gonna have to deal with that
anyway the other fights they were great
lots of nice strategy and techniques but
this was on a whole new level
watching two out of these world figures
do battle is exactly what
dude face said it was like oh god what's
his name kusa kuzakabe
the guy with the things the coward but
the funny coward i like him anyway he
equated it to elephants tap dancing on
ants no
actually he didn't he that was sukuna vs
joker holy crap my brain what is wrong
with my brain shibuya has done
some stuff to me so you know what maybe
sukuniverse's jogo was the fight of the
ark actually that was pretty damn cool
as well but so was anything involving
sukuna he was captivating because it was
great to see him
somewhat let loose and during his entire
time of release akutami very much made a
point of emphasizing just how evil
sukuna actually is quite literally
calling him overwhelmingly evil which is
i think something that very much needed
to be done
tsukuna at this point risks becoming a
character who is more likeable than he
is alarming like there's a very charming
and even comical nature with him in
yuji's body but during this arc we were
well and truly reminded that yes he is
indeed
an unimaginable monster there was also
this kind of great fu moment against
drogo where sukuna claimed that he
wouldn't cheat by revealing what his
cursed technique is thus seemingly
making it more powerful if he were to do
that
basically handicapping himself because
jogo what a
joke except he really isn't when he's
not facing off against tsukuna or gojo
jogo is an absolute beast but he just
gets very unlucky with opponents anyway
i love the whole sukino refusing to
reveal his curse technique thing
because that is the entire reason why
this mechanic exists to give akutami an
easy out for explaining cursed
techniques that's
literally it it's purely a narrative
device so to see that subverted here
creates fun intrigue and i guess
and a little bit of smack talk as well
which was pretty brilliant and
man he's capable of i don't even know
what he's capable of because he didn't
reveal it but it certainly isn't
confined to like cleaving and
dismantling
showing that there is a whole new layer
of power out there oh
no malevolent shrine it was wonderful to
see this domain again especially being
poetically equated to a painter
constructing a masterpiece on air rather
than on canvas
i love that kind of language but also
this was really devastating because
sukuno just up and murdered everyone
within its
impressively large radius and a curious
little detail that was dropped here is
that apparently one can escape the
malevolent shrine which does not apply
to other domains and that is the
trade-off for the huge range so look
that's a
very intriguing thing to know for the
future i imagine
it may be relevant and there were just a
couple of i guess
odd moments with tsukuner as well one of
which was this really touching
conversation with jogo right on the
verge of death coming to this
understanding and even sukan is saying
that jogo
you should be proud and stuff and am i
wrong to question whether or not this
actually happened or if this was like a
ug
style memory implant thing it was just
weird
in a good way gives me something to
think about and once again throw sukuna
into like direct juxtaposition with gojo
which was already a comparison
made by jogo himself but gojo if i
recall pretty much
his pistol over jogo calling him
ridiculously weak and now he's tsukuna
doing the opposite calling him strong in
this very
comforting way then again i don't know
because tsukuna also pissed all over
joko during
the fight laying down some verbal
smackdown such as
the moonlight's illumination makes it
easier to see how pathetic you are
so yeah i'm just i'm left questing this
moment quite a bit it's so
very very out of place and out of
character not that we know a lot about
sukuna's character to be fair so
maybe it isn't what's also interesting
is that tsukuna willingly gave yuji
control of his body again with big bad
demon daddy having some sort of more
long-term plan here i don't know it
happened
and then more things happened many more
things in fact
i feel like i barely touched on anything
because i haven't even mentioned
mahito yet not properly anyway just like
sukuna's evil nature was emphasized
akutami very much went all out with
mojito's grotesque view of life which
makes sense this was his moment after
all or was it spoilers it was not but
his story intersects with so many other
characters that you know you forgive me
for jumping around a bit here
tragedy first yes none of me i hate
mahito mostly because i love nanami and
it was such a
bitter feeling to see him meet his end
quite literally at the hands of majito
especially after having escaped the
domain all those arcs ago
after that anonymity felt quite
invincible or at least that's what i was
hoping he would be so in a sickening way
i do appreciate the decision to kill him
especially with his final words to yuji
he was a fantastic mentor and yuji is
going to carry all of that going forward
so rest in peace
at your malaysian beachfront in the sky
good sir alright slight
malaysia related tangent here speaking
of malaysia we actually see meimei in
malaysia during the um
the sort of conclusion of the arc
because it's also not the conclusion
it's like the point right before the
climax doesn't matter how did she get
there so quickly and wasn't she like
about to fight ghetto
or i guess not ghetto at some point i'll
admit kind of loss with meimei's
timeline so i'm guessing that either she
or her brother can
teleport as a curse technique in
addition to you know
having sex like i mean that's not a
curse technique but is that what's
happening here there's a lot of very
interesting implications in this hotel
room scene lots of questions that arise
many of which probably
just better left untouched you know just
like oui if you're maymay
cause he's underage whatever the hell
happened here though it was really
jarring and it took me out of the
action-packed climax that was happening
around it much like how it just
completely derailed this review actually
but
what then what happened with maymay if
i've missed something please do point it
out
i don't quite understand why she's there
don't quite understand it all and look
i'll even read the comments if you do
have a satisfying answer given how close
i am to finishing the series but while
we're on things like that there was not
just one but two
quote special chapters during the
shibuya rock both of which came at
wonderfully hugely inappropriate times
just as we were about to settle things
and i'm guessing akutami was under an
exceptional amount of pressure at this
point missing deadlines and such and as
a result he had to pump out the
short short chapters with big big panels
you know very low
production value stuff and yes they were
they were fun to read because the
characters of jiu-jitsu kaisen are just
fun in general it's just that they came
at the worst
possible time right when yuji vs majito
was about to end ah mahito that's that's
where i started that's what i was
talking about like i said his part in
the arc intersects with just about
everyone and another huge factor would
be kugisaki because
damn was she glorious during the sock i
love the way that she handed mojito's
ass to him with resonance and it very
much highlights what i love about power
systems like this because
one matchup of weird abilities that can
really be the end of you and she was
glorious
right up until the end i suppose now
that was a shock a character like naomi
yeah sure i can expect him to die he's a
mental figure after all and mental
figures are
practically cursed today but kugisaki
man she's the next generation her death
pretty seriously rocked me to my core
and it was such a
magnificent way for her to go out with
her last words and everything
i am sad shocked but satisfied now with
that said
please please please let her stay dead
might sound like a harsh thing to say
but this was such a brilliant moment do
not undercut it by having some dude
state that look her chances of being
alive aren't
zero percent maybe that just gives me
the worst sinking feeling in the world
and if this was most other shown series
i would take that as practically a
guarantee that she will survive
i guess the thing about jujutsu kaisen
is that akitami does handle death and
resurrection even
pretty well like the toji example so if
kukisaki does come back into the story
then i'm willing to think that there's a
satisfying and hopefully costly way to
do so but please no outright
resurrections i beg of you
back to mahito though actually no let's
talk about yuji he reaches
a thorough breaking point during shibuya
one that i thought would be taking him
to a very dark place however luckily he
happens to have a supportive alter
brother and todo does make his glorious
presence known i was wondering where he
was during the first half but he is used
to
absolute perfection here he's such a
good foil for mahito and a great
supporting presence for yuji and there
were just too many great todo moments in
his short tenure to name here
would be a very long list but my
favorite is undoubtedly when he pulled
the old clap trick right at the end
claiming that applause is the
accumulation of the soul distracting
mahito and allowing yuji to do the thing
and all i'm going to say is at this
moment it was
very isaac natural no spoilers from
hunter hunter but very similar vibes and
yeah toto absolutely
makes this fight it's a great escalation
of when he and yuji took on hanumi
and just super satisfying to read but to
actually discuss majito
i've left him to the end because i'm
honestly kind of underwhelmed by him and
in retrospect
that was probably the point the thing i
disliked most was his final form because
final forms
always look like garbage and he is no
exception we abandoned his cool
patchwork design to assume this
is really sort of standard curse thing
which had absolutely no character about
it whatsoever and at that point it might
as well have been yuji fighting any
miscellaneous super special curse dude
because really the crowning feature of
mahito is his emotion and facial
expression sort of like how i said at
least 50 percent of goja's character is
purely in his hands well the same
applies to mahi toba with his face so
once you take away that face and replace
it with this
fleshy wall with a sort of mouth he just
became
insanely boring and that state it was a
really pitiful climax to what had been
such a compelling character and once
again yeah that may very well be
intentional because the big revelation
at the end of this arc is that yes
mojito was more or less meaningless he
was
essentially a delicious snack he was
there to be grown like livestock and
then consumed by
the ghetto okay ghetto not ghetto
noritoshikamo
not him either though i don't know he
has many names apparently this is where
the bombardment of information was
really taken to the extreme so firstly i
do love the idea that this entire saga
of jiu-jitsu kaisen has been a mere
portion of some sort of grander plan to
do with the ghetto figure he certainly
did
eyes and the hell out of this story and
these last few chapters just ceded so
much insane crap like that little moment
of cutting to samiki with the stuff on
her head
saying stuff like all cursed objects
have now been unsealed and a wild
revelatory statement like
like adjusting brains is that what he
did adjusting brains for sorcery and
vessel strength and all sorts of madness
not even going to pretend that i have
taken everything in because ghetto
said a lot of things i'm definitely
gonna have to go back on it all i know
is that allegedly we are returning to
the world of haiyan there's a
maximum uzumaki and the golden age of
cursed techniques is upon us and very
frustratingly this is where the ark
seems to
officially end so i legitimately have no
idea where we're going from here what i
do know is that this arc was a very
bitter defeat
after all of this we didn't save gojo we
lost very lovable characters like nanami
kugisaki mekamaru actually he had a very
touching goodbye and did we ever find
out what happened to maki and nobito
didn't they get like the crap burnt out
of them too the villains we thought we
were fighting were not
really the villains like i i did feel
for the nature cursed spirit gang
they were pricks more specifically jogo
was a prick but they weren't evil at
heart
and now the world has been immeasurably
ruined by a big bad
actually evil dude and all i can say is
that thankfully at least we still have
panda so there is some hope here i mean
i haven't even spoken about choso either
to be fair
he didn't really do anything unexpected
and very happy to have him as what i
think
is an ally now but he's cool and so
that's that and also there's probably a
million other things i haven't mentioned
either because this is a review remember
not an analysis but shibuya
utter insanity this arc simultaneously
paid everything off that was set up for
it as well as set up an incredible
amount to come after it the story the
interactions the combat all of it was
fascinating and jujitsu
sin deserves all of the accumulation of
soul-based applause for pulling off
its first major narrative climax but
that pretty much does it for this blind
review of jiu-jitsu
sen shibuya incident dark and what do
you guys think please do leave your
thoughts in the comments below or even
join my discord server and if you're
keen for some more jiu jitsu sorcery
then please do check out some of my
other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for very maybe
regular jujutsu morbidity delivered
straight into your youtube feed but for
now this has been the new world review
and i'm going to go and lie down